Before we move on to understanding the
concept of a unit circle let us review what we did previously The
code we use to
remember the formula is so that so tells
us that sa theta is
opposite by hypotenuse  And that tells us
theta is opposite by
adjacent the are the three basic formulas we
use in trigonometry but how are
those three functions related to the
angle theta what happens to them when theta
changes are they are directly and inversely proportional
to theta all these questions can
B Answered With The Help Of One Concept
Called The Unit Circle The concept of this
circle is very simple to represent the
Cartesian plane Let's draw the x and the y
axis
The unit circle would look like this It is a
circle with radius equal to one unit  And it
has its center at the origin and is the point at which the
The y axis is also at
two points. Let's
find the coordinates of two
points. This
point lies on the one axis. This
means its y coordinate will be 1. The radius
of the circle is y. Its x
coordinate will be
1.  0 What about the coordinates of this
point simply it will be -1 0 As it is on the
negative side of the x x axis What about this
point as it lies on the y axis Its
x coordinate will be row and the radius is
one unit Its coordinates will  B 0 1
Similarly the coordinates of this point
here will be B 0
-1 This is the unit circle but how does this
circle help us understand the relation between
theta and the trigonometry functions Let's
C Let these be our x and y axes and let this
B  Our unit
circle we draw a right triangle this way we
draw it true that the hypotenuse of the
triangle is the radius of the unit circle so
the hypotenuse will be one unit and we let this angle be theta this
triangle is the
same one we have seen  Or just that we keep its
hypotenuse equal to the radius of
the unit circle which is one unit let's call
it o a in this triangle o is the
hypotenuse o a will be the adjacent side
and a will be the opposite side now let's apply the
Formula and see the
results first let's find out sa theta it's soka tva
so sign is opposite by
hypotenuse
opposite is
abs2 but what is o o is equal to 1 unit
as it is the
radius so with will be
hypotenuse is o hence ka theta will equal
o a  Bao and edge o is v unit k theta will
equal o a so let's right k theta under o a
here o a is k theta and a is sa theta What about tan3 t is
actually a tange function the length
of tan3 will be the length of the tange it
From point b to the x axis which is the
length of this green line this green line touches
the circle at just one point which is
point b this length will be
tan3 From this figure we have the length of sa theta
k theta and tan3 now  Understand the
Relation Between the Angle Theta and the Functions We
Just Have to Try Changing the Angle Theta and See How These
Three Lengths Change We See That
in the Next Part of the
[Music]
Video